en france le gouvernement veut lutter
contre le piratage sur internet une
charte a été présenté aujourd'hui en
présence de tous les acteurs du secteur
elles prévoient des mises en garde mais
aussi des sanctions allant jusqu'à
l'interruption des abonnements par les
fournisseurs de réseaux
marie-claire tiers stéphane taponier ce
film n'est pas encore sorti en dvd
pourtant max la télécharger en toute
illégalité et le possède maintenant chez
lui par un simple clic
ça m'a coûté 20 centimes d'euro car j'ai
acheter les cd par 100 à la place un dvd
ça contre 20 et 25 euros
le dvd à au magasin max en a comme ça
des centaines un vrai cinéma gratuit à
domicile et même chose pour la musique
sur un seul cd pour moins d'un euro
il peut avoir jusqu'à 50 albums ils sont
comme lui des centaines de milliers en
france à pratiquer ce téléchargement
sauvage selon l'industrie du disque ce
piratage lui coûte un tiers de son
chiffre d'affaires par an c'est pour
lutter contre ce phénomène que ce matin
les ministres de l'économie de
l'industrie de la culture se sont mis
d'accord avec les professionnels sur un
projet de charte
trois mesures message d'avertissement
sur les écrans fin des abonnements pour
ceux qui persistent promouvoir l'offre
légale de musique en ligne
j'espère que ça va être efficace on l'a
pu voir aux états unis après les
premières actions effectivement la
piraterie avait sérieusement baissé et
sachez que depuis ces actions là le
marché du 10
physique est reparti pendant que en même
temps les offres payantes raffin explosé
aux états unis pour le repérage des
pirates
le système repose sur les fournisseurs
d'accès aujourd'hui encore très peu de
procès l'important c'est ce qu'il y ait
une prise de conscience générale de tous
sur le caractère illicite de la
piraterie qu'en pense max et les
internautes
je vous assure que dans la semaine dans
les cageots qui suit ils vont trouver la
parade pour éviter de se faire opérer et
pourtant cela risque de leur coûter très
cher jusqu'à 300 mille euros d'amendé et
trois ans de prison
réfléchissez avant de piquer